[Musique]
le petit déjeuner politique via venu le
petit déjeuner politique sud radio 17h42
avec bruno retailleau ce matin sénateur
de vendée et président du groupe l'est
républicain au sénat le président de
forces républicaines bonjour bruno
retailleau
bonjour patrick la mobilisation des
policiers yaris que les réponses du
ministre castaner sont à la hauteur
défense du système de retraite paiement
des heures sup embauche de dix mille
policiers révision de la prime de risque
c'est pas mal ça non non mais il n'a pas
été au fond des choses nous avons fait
il ya un an au sénat une commission
denquête parce que nous avions constaté
il ya deux ans un pic dans le suicide
notamment des policiers et des chants
d'art et bien sûr qu'à des questions de
moyens il ya 22 millions d'heures
supplémentaires keane qui ne sont pas
payés mais ça n'est pas qu'une question
de moyens c'est aussi une question de
considération on a d'un côté une société
qui de plus en plus violente plus en
plusieurs vis-à-vis des forces de
l'ordre et on voit bien qu'il ya pour
des délinquants parfois une impunité
j'ai auditionné mois des policiers
notamment d'un grand syndicat qui me
disaient qu'il y en a marre lorsque on a
des dealers qui sont des mineurs souvent
et bien sûr ils les prennent il est
remettent à la justice
et quelques jours après ces dealers ils
les retrouvent dans la rue en train de
l'énarque et tant que le rapporteur à
l'époque de cette commission denquête
qui était le sénateur françois
grosdidier avait une image je trouve
excellente
ils avaient dit les gendarmes et les
policiers ont sentiment d'être sur un
vélo de pédaler sur un vélo qui n'a pas
de chaîne y'a rien de plus désespérant
que d'exercer une mission de service
public est de constater que il ya une
forme d'impunité et je pense que la
réponse à devrait être pénales quelle
est la différence de politique pénale
qu'on me le dise aujourd'hui oui entre
celle de madame taubira et de madame
bello mais on avait promis la réponse
d'orsoni en place de prison je ne sais
même pas si on aura mille à la fin du
quinquennat qui auraient été construites
oui donc il ya pas qu une question
effectivement de moyens pour les
policiers eux mêmes mais c'est aussi
d'aller dans le camp aussi de l'aviron
les autres ouvrons les yeux tous nos
grands services publics connaissent un
grand malaise
on a aujourd'hui puisqu'il ya une jeune
directrice d'école maternelle qui s'est
suicidé voilà et ayez un mouvement chez
les enseignants donc l'école les
urgences le service public de la santé
et puis bien sûr et policiers avec les
pompiers aussi services de sécurité
civile tous les grands services publics
français sont en crise que fait alors il
faudrait est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas un
grand débat autour de ces thèmes alors
non justement justement le problème le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que mails
macro n'est pas tellement un
hyperprésident c'est d'abord un nid père
quand ita est ce qu'on lui demande ça
n'est pas de débattre at vitam aeternam
pour se mettre en scène sans doute
peut-être pour gagner l'élection dans
quelques années présidentielles mais de
prendre des décisions
en réalité la méthode de demel macron
c'est que il semble faire mais il fait
semblant
il semble affrontant il eu sur les
terrains il est donc le débat sur les
retraites qui lance aujourd'hui la
semaine prochaine sur l'immigration veut
bien vous la cote r non je veux bien
vous l'accordé oui il est partout sauf à
rouen oui il ya rodez sauf à rouen mais
où où les choses se passent coûts et la
crise aujourd'hui en france
c'est à rodez ou est ce que c'est un
rond ouais c'est pas la veyron c'est la
seine maritime
dans ce cas j'attends du président la
république qu'ils arrêtent de se met en
scène qui réforment vraiment sans faire
semblant
le pays parce que vous verrez on est au
bord de la crise et on voit bien que il
ya un malaise qui est en train de se
propager et ce malaise ailleurs il est
accrue par une dimension politique
qu'est ce que t'en d'installer mail
macron en privant les français de leur
choix cette idée d'un duel trône à mme
le pen et lui autant dire que y'a plus
le choix de vote
voilà et ça je pense que ce débouché
politique qui est extrêmement réduit à
ce choix cornélien encourage un malaise
social est une expression qui peut être
parfois plus violente dans la rue ces
nuages eu faute alors en tout cas c'est
une faute selon vous bruno retailleau
que emmanuel macron ne se soit pas
encore rendu à roy mais bien sûr enfin
je veux dire que il ya une immense
inquiétude
je trouve que l'état il faut faire très
attention je pense que les oppositions
toutes les bonnes réponses aussi
peut-être un jour du salut est-ce que
l'opposition n'est pas traumatisé le fun
justement faisant très attention parce
que nous sommes dans l'ère du soupçon et
je crois que il faut manier les choses
avec une pince est simplement je pensais
ce que nous allons faire au sénat c'est
que on a un rôle institutionnel et nous
allons créer par exemple non pas comme
l'a fait l'assemblée
mission d'information mais une vraie une
vraie mission dans une commission
denquête oui parce qu'au sénat on sait
très bien que les commission denquête si
rigoureux c'est sérieux servir alors
commission mais de tirer les leçons
moi vous savez j'ai vécu dans mon
département il ya vingt ans une
catastrophe écologique
l'erika je me souviens de league one et
qui nous avait dit que c'était pas
vraiment une catastrophe
j'ai vécu ensuite il ya dix ans bientôt
dans dans quelques mois une autre
catastrophe
cette exit ya 29 morts donc il faut y
faire attention mais chaque catastrophe
on doit en tirer les leçons pour que ça
ne se reproduise pas l'objectif de la
commission denquête ce sera d'éclairer
bien sûr les choses de voir comment pas
amélioré le système ça sera d'apporter
de la transparence je vous annonce à ce
micro que nous avons déjà présélectionné
le sénat trois grands cabinets
incontestable pour que l'on puisse avoir
nos propres informations indépendantes
sur sa scientifique alors au tiff
identifie sur les produits sur la
manière dont sont gérés suis sûr squale
la grande question c'est que ouais quand
ces produits brûle
ensemble ils produisent autre chose que
un plus un font d'eux si j'ose dire
tiers que il se recombinent les
molécules et c'est là qu'on ne sait pas
et je je je veux des douaniers le
gouvernement et ceux qui pensent que le
gouvernement est en train de mentir sur
le long terme là on veut aussi des
répondants logo terre n'en voudrons viol
non une commission denquête faut de
sérieux
justement on est attaché très court au
piquet de l'instant une commission
denquête c'est à la fois révélé toutes
les informations en toute transparence
bien sûr mais aussi de tirer des
enseignements pour que ça ne se
reproduise pas c'est ça le travail de
fond d'une mission d'enquêté
vous savez on sera au rendez vous on a
montré dans le passé que quand le sénat
fait une commission denquête croyez moi
c'est pas pour rire il le fait à fond et
en toute indépendance sur nous encore un
mot sur sur les policiers la colère
d'hier parce que vous l'avez évoqué vous
mettez là la balle dans le camp de
nicole belloubet
également ce plan marshall que vous avez
évoqué un moment pour les policiers qui
skie qu'est ce qu'il comprend qu est-ce
qu il y aurait en fait à l'intérieur
en réalité aujourd'hui pour que les
auditeurs comprennent bien sûr les
moyens affectés à la police il ya 90 %
qui vont la masse salariale il faut
payer bien sûr les policiers sauf que on
ne remet pas d'ailleurs les heures
supplémentaires est une partie des
promesses pour les yeux
quand vous avez plus de policiers une
masse salariale il faut aussi mieux les
équipes et parce que s'il ya plus de
policiers mais que l'équipement ne suis
pas l'investissement ne fuit pas ne suis
pas en matière de voitures en matière de
casques en matière de d'habillement et
cetera il ya un vrai de vrai problème
mais encore une fois en france on se
trompe totalement depuis une trentaine
d'années en considérant que le niveau
d'efficacité des services publics est
dépendant du niveau de la dépense
publique si c'était ça nous qui avons la
dépense publique la plus forte au monde
mais on aurait les services publics les
plus géniaux au monde
on a des policiers on a des médecins des
infirmières et des instituteurs qui sont
totalement dévoués mais ils sont
aujourd'hui thé courage et oui et je
pense qu'à aussi de vraies réformes
il ya une crise de l'état qui est une
crise d'autorité et on a j'ai fait il ya
quelques semaines un colloque au sénat
sur comment régler les choses pour
ressortir l'impunité il ya deux grands
exemples l'exemple de new york aux états
unis
c'est l'échelle d'une agglomération bien
sûr mais c'est l'impunité zéro il ya
l'autre exemple beaucoup plus un pays
les pays bas
pas très loin de chez nous où la ces des
courtes peines
les gens peuvent aller en prison sur des
courtes peines ils vont pas longtemps
mais les prisons sont vides alors que
les nôtres elles sont surpeuplées non
mais d'un mot je n'ai pas bien compris
quand même au niveau des moyens parce
que vous dites que 90 % vont
effectivement donc est pour et qui j'ai
alors les policiers ont alors il faut
des crédits supplémentaires
je prie le message que j'essaie de vous
donner c'est que on ne pourra pas
améliorer le système un système qui
fonctionne mal en déversant toujours
plus de moyens
le point crucial est que la procédure
les procédures administratives
judiciaires pour les policiers sont trop
lourdes
donc on les bloque au bureau plutôt que
d'être sur le terrain mais surtout qu'il
faut une réponse pénale à la hauteur et
la politique pénale française c'est le
cran fiasco et donc il faut choisir
est-ce qu'on quitte une politique qui
n'a pas marché qui produit trop
d'impunité qui produit une désespérance
dans nos forces de l'ordre ou est ce que
on fait vraiment une rupture web et
bruno retailleau
vous l'avez évoqué suicides de policiers
directeur d'école d'agriculteurs de
beaucoup de professions il n'y aurait
pas une nouvelle commission à mettre en
place justement autour de tous ces
suicides quand même on à l'huile depuis
quelques années et on a l'impression que
ça que je ne sais qu'on fait ce qui est
terrible c'est que on est cette
commission au sénat pour les forces de
l'ordre et gendarmes et les policiers la
bonne intuition complément à tirer des
conclusions le problème c'est que le
gouvernement n'en tient pas compte et je
crois qu'en deux ans les choses
malheureusement se sont empirées pour
voir autant de deux milliers de milliers
de policiers dans la rue
tous les syndicats ont appelé à
manifester c'est du jamais vu je crois
depuis plus de 20 ans ça devrait ouvrir
les yeux ouvernement est encore une fois
bien sûr il ya des moyens notamment en
matériel c'est ce que je vous disais je
est bien sûr places de prison mais c'est
autre chose c'est la considération c'est
cette crise autorités de l'état et cette
crise autorités on y répondra que par de
la fermeté l'impunité zéro
oui la réforme des retraites il est sur
la bonne voie quand même emmanuel macron
avait fusionné en fait j'ai système
je ne peux pas vous dire parce que c'est
le grand flou je pense justement que
c'est aussi un problème monsieur delvoye
était censé consulter concertée pendant
près de deux ans 18 mois et puis on
repart sur un double 6 on voit bien que
le gouvernement hésite je pense que le
système à points
c'est le grand fantasme des élites
technocratiques à la française qui
veulent un système un seul système un
peu à peu se vêtit fort or aujourd'hui
on peut aller dans le mur parce que pour
les avocats pour les infirmières
libérales etc pour les instituteurs
d'ailleurs aussi les professeurs des
écoles on risque d'avoir beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de perdants tôt que
moi je pense que il ya un point qui est
absolument très nette
on doit garantir que le président de
république nous dise comment il va
garantir pour l'avenir le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités
il refuse il a pris un engagement
pendant sa campagne de ne pas reculer
l'âge de départ légal à la retraite au
delà de 62 ans cet intenable
la proposition que je fais voyez que on
peut dans l'opposition mais aussi à
perdre est votre position exigeantes
c'est de repousser progressivement à 64
puis 65 ans pourquoi parce que là on
donne à nos retraités ont garanti le
pouvoir d'achat qu'est ce qu'il a fait
mais le maquereau et après 66 ans dont
24 ans puis sa patte sur une dizaine
d'années gens rire que j'arrive pas vous
êtes sûr qu'une tribu situation est
annoncé je veux dire là aussi il faut
comprendre moi je suis pas démago quand
monsieur mitterrand en 81
mais la passe la retraite de 65 à 60 ans
l'espérance de vie est de 74 ans
aujourd'hui l'espérance de vie est à 83
ans
on sait bien qu'il ya un problème or là
or là qu'est ce qui va se passer dès
cette année la branche vieillesse de la
sécurité sociale
elle plonge dans le rouge et donc
monsieur macron est rattrapé par la
patrouille
il ne pourra pas nous ne pourrons pas
attendre 2025 pour faire une réforme du
système je propose donc que yes est ce
recul de l'âge pour garantir un le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités pour
augmenter les petites retraites mais
bien pour tout le monde si c'est pas
pour tout le monde si en fonction des
difficultés au grand gîte et hop une ré
attendait une une réforme c'est une
bonne réforme c'est quoi une bonne
réforme
c'est une réforme évidemment qu'ils
conservent le pouvoir d'achat retraités
c'est une réforme qui préserve les
quitter bref plus de régimes spéciaux
évidemment oui dimanche prochain est ce
que vous serez
sur le terrain pour manifester contre
l'ouverture de la pma aux femmes
je vais lutter contre ce texte qui me
choque personnellement même si je
comprends parfaitement la souffrance le
désir d'enfant je comprends simplement
si on estime que les enfants n'ont pas
besoin de père qu'on me le prouve qu'on
me le prouve
si je veux dire que moi je suis prête
convaincu si scientifiquement on dit les
enfants n'ont pas besoin de pain aux
pauvres
si il ya une hésitation pourquoi est ce
que on n'utiliserait pas le principe de
précaution on a joué les apprentis
sorciers sur l'environnement sur la
nature et là on est prêts à faire sauter
toutes les limites donc moi je pense
qu'il faut y aller responsablement je ne
manifesterai pas parce que pourquoi
parce que contrairement au match pour
tout je trouve que on est en train de
faire éclater les clivages
il ya beaucoup de voix de gauche je
pense à sylviane agacinski à natacha
polony à josé bové et à bien d'autres
qui qui rejoignent cette position la
position que j'exprime et je pense qu'il
faut pas trop politiser cette
manifestation mais je je comprends très
bien et j'encourage ceux d'ailleurs qui
veulent s'exprimer à pour le faire
simplement moi je peux me manifester
j'ose dire sans manifester puisque voilà
je vous me donnez la parole et et
j'aurai aussi la parole au moment du de
l'examen par le sénat du texte bruno
retailleau le mot de la fin avec cécile
de ménibus julien aubert et à guillaume
larrivé deux prétendants à la présidence
des républicains apportent leur soutien
à eric zemmour
au nom de la liberté d'expression ils
ont signé donc la pétition est ce que
vous allez la signer aussi aux non gelé
ça vraiment les pétitions c'est pas mon
truc
écoutez moi en tout cas je suis
absolument mais absolument réfractaires
à la dérive d'une judiciarisation du
débat public
ça ne m'empêche pas de ne pas être
d'accord avec eric zemmour je pense que
moi je suis d'accord sur tout surtout ce
qu'il a dit non je suis trop fan
m'empêche pas de ne pas être d'accord
ado ne pas être au départ on n'a pas de
ne pas être d'accord avec eric zamo tout
simplement je pense que la politique ce
n'est pas de se rendre à la fatalité
cette porte aussi une espérance je pense
que la politique
ça n'est pas d'organiser ou de susciter
une discorde civile
c'est au contraire d'organiser une
concorde civile et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense que il faut à la fois
combattre le politiquement correct et
voir ce que l'on voit et le dénoncer et
vous pensez que c'est une erreur et je
pense que cache cette base une partie de
l'islam politique qui est en train de
miner un certain nombre de quartiers et
l'ordre républicain
vous avez des grands enquêtes qui sont
parus qui où vous avez pratiquement 30%
27 % de ceux qui professent la
confession musulmane qui considère que
la charia est au dessus des lois de la
république ça c'est inacceptable
nous allons proposer au sénat une
proposition de loi pour interdire les
femmes voilées dans les sorties
scolaires ne le fallait qui la signe
cette pétition est ce que vous et non
mais cette aube coûté autant d on est
dans un pays de liberté elles viendront
pas ma propre liberté et et si je dis
que je suis réfractaire à la
judiciarisation du débat public c'est
parce que je pense que la liberté
d'expression est important mais ça ne
m'empêche pas de dire pourquoi je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ces propos là si
bruno retailleau sénateur de vendée
président du groupe l'est républicain au
sénat et président de forces
républicaines qui était l'invité ce
matin de sud ratier dans un instant
reviendra sur le break site avec les
déclarations de boris johnson à
bruxelles 7h57 cedro matin sur radio
grandin sud radio
[Musique]